we are quickly learning the full scope
of what William bar as Donald Trump's
Attorney General is expected to be doing
by Donald Trump and his cronies William
bar is expected and did propagandize
Donald Trump's alleged innocence in the
Russia scandal William bar is expected
to interfere with anything that might
lead to Donald Trump's taxes being
provided to anybody even State
investigators and most recently William
bar was expected and implored by Donald
Trump to hold a bogus propaganda press
conference during which Barr would come
out and say Donald Trump did nothing
wrong in the Ukraine Joe Biden phone
call Fiasco The Washington Post has a
really well sourced article by three of
their top reporters and they can now
report that Donald Trump wanted his
attorney General William Bar to hold a
news conference and in that news
conference
William Barr was expected to say Donald
Trump didn't break any laws during the
Ukraine phone call or in anything
related to that fiasco this happened
right around the time when the Ukraine
phone call news went public and Donald
Trump put out that completely bogus
partial transcript and Barr ultimately
refused to do it shocking actually and
reportedly Trump and Barr are still on
good terms despite bars refusal now you
might remember that at the time a
Justice Department spokeswoman said you
know we looked generally at whether any
campaign finance laws were likely broken
by the phone call we don't think any
further action is warranted but clearly
that is not what Donald Trump wanted and
clearly what Donald Trump wanted in
william bar going out and making this
declaration about trump's vindication
exceeded the scope of what william bar
would really be in a position to do you
know for a guy in trump who has been
complaining about no due process
suggesting that an attorney general make
an exonerating legal statement a
positive exonerating legal statement
about a matter which he has not actually
investigated and which has not actually
come before the Justice Department in
any formal way that's not the legal
process we have in this country but of
course following the right processes
only matters
if it's a process that's convenient to
Donald Trump that Donald Trump likes
otherwise it doesn't matter it's
whatever Trump wants now the bigger
question here is actually whether
William Bar was involved in some way in
the Ukraine Fiasco because I want to be
really clear here in this latest story
the question is why did Barr refuse to
do what Trump asked and isn't Barr a
great guy for refusing to do it but one
of the things that William Barr was
quick to do from the time that the
Ukraine story broke was to immediately
distance himself from any involvement in
it and it's not clear that William Barr
wasn't involved because remember in the
phone call with the Ukrainian president
zolensky at least in the parts that
Trump released in the bogus partial
transcript Trump refers to I'm gonna
have William bar get in touch with
Ukrainian prosecutors to look into
Hillary's emails and to look into Joe
Biden as far as Trump is saying in the
call William bar was involved or was
soon going to be involved now of course
the Justice Department is maintaining
that the first time bar ever heard about
any of this was when the partial
transcript was released but does anybody
believe that that does anybody think
that that is the most likely scenario
there are reports that Barr was
regularly pulled into things like this
before including one instance where
Donald Trump spoke on the phone with the
Australian prime minister Scott Morrison
and Trump told Morrison hey can you help
my attorney General William Barre gather
information to help us investigate
Robert Moeller if you can imagine
there's a report of William Bar meeting
with Italian officials about other
investigations meant to be favorable to
Donald Trump there are reports that
William bar was in touch with British
intelligence officials under strange
circumstances and for opaque purposes so
every indication here is that William
bar is just as dirty as Trump in this
entire thing so allowing William bard to
come away as the ethical one because he
didn't go out there and say the
president broke no laws something which
would have been a stretch even for
William bard to do about something which
he had not investigated we can skip that
altogether and let's keep the focus on
the important issue
is at hand here which is it seems like
William bar is involved in all of this
trumpian nonsense he may be part of the
problem and if so if this actually
becomes a matter for the Justice
Department
William bar needs to recuse himself
there are actually already calls from
legal scholars saying anything even
remotely associated with Donald Trump
and Ukraine and Biden corruption
whatever the case may be if it's even
remotely associated with that William
bar cannot oversee it he needs to recuse
himself because he appears to be just as
involved as Rudy Giuliani Giuliani call
him what you will and a lot of these
other people that have been slowly but
surely pulled into it of course they're
not going to do it Donald Trump Donald
Trump has already made clear that when
attorney generals when attorneys general
recuse themselves from things that
involve Trump they end up losing their
jobs as Jeff Sessions is proof of by the
way Jeff Sessions is running for Senate
again we will talk about that on the
bonus show but for now we will take a
quick break make sure to give us a like
on Facebook at facebook.com slash David
Pakman show and follow me on tick-tock
what are we doing on tick-tock I don't
know but we're on they're at David
Pakman show on tick-tock